triste
c'est à saint venant de paquette un
village de 98 habitants situé en estrie
que se trouve le jardin de richard
séguin le lieu est tellement inspirant
qu'il y vit depuis 50 ans avec sa
conjointe faudrait voir le ménage mais
c'est un fait que les mafieux on était
on sent à l'aise au sein puisque c'est
une équipe incroyable
pour moi là et puis mais pour nous deux
quand on fait ce métier là
il y a d'ailleurs beaucoup de saint
venant sur le nouvel album de richard
séguin intitulé les liens les lieux sa
poésie il la met au service de dame
nature oui mais question de lien lien
avec la famille ni avec la nature ni
avec des amitiés lien avec le village
comme tel et puis au niveau des lieux
c'est l'ancrage du territoire
parmi les dix nouvelles chansons il y en
a une pour son père le garage et pour sa
mère il a écrit tout près des trembles
tout près d'être
je n'avais jamais composé de deux
chansons pour ma mère et on il doit
beaucoup à la dent dans la famille parce
que c'est elle
introduit la culture dans la maison
c'est vrai qu'avec avait des livres a
fait en sorte qu'il y avait un piano
c'est après coup on se rend compte et
ses ligues là c'est un qu'il pense à
nous
sans que
richard séguin a aussi écrit une chanson
pour son ami florent vollant et il s'est
entouré de nombreux collaborateurs dont
l'écrivaine hélène dorion premier texte
qui ouvre l'album
c'est son écriture et ça dit il est déjà
minuit dans la forêt du monde
qu'est-ce qu'on a trahi pour que l'orage
gronde
juste là c'est la dualité de
s'apercevoir qu'on est dans une époque
qui peut être cahotique hacker
changement climatique via du ccre et
rieur richard séguin s'apprête à quitter
saint venant momentanément pour une
journée de 80 concerts qui la mènera aux
quatre coins du québec et si la grande
forme ben parce que saint venant ses
joues vance
[Rires]
mais je compte à queue à mon âge plus
encore fin des chansons
modifie à la grande faucheuse
[Rires]
ici louis philippe ouimet radio canada à
saint venant de paquette
[Musique]